allez les chéris hier soir M6 diffusait
un nouveau numéro de l'amour est dans le
il s'est passé beaucoup de choses hier
un épisode de fou épisode de fou alors
il y avait Jean-Paul et Maria d'abord
c'est la rigolade de l'épisode d'hier il
y a Maria qui a reproché à Jean-Paul
d'être arrivé avec 2h30 de retard vous
allez voir quand elle surgit de derrière
un buisson pendant l'interview de
Jean-Paul ça nous offre pour moi un des
moments les plus drôles de l'histoire
d'amour de l'amour et dans le prê
regardez quoi ben il a dit que c'était
pas de sa faute les 2h de retard que
c'était de la faute des tournesol de la
météo il a été de mauvaise fois il a pas
dit excuse-moi il a rien de préc qui se
passe mais disons que Maria cétait une
femme amoureuse de moi faut savoir ce
qu'on veut on est ensemble on est plus
je suis désolé il a parlé de changer
d'avis je n'ai jamais changé d'avis
attention faut pas faut pas dire des
choses que j'ai pas dit ne sois pas de
mauvaise fois moi je te parle que de
mauvaise fois et tu estu tu vux
arrivriver 2h30 en retard hier la vie
c'est toute une organisation mais non
mais
dagarrive de derrière c'est très très
fort je do de le revoir tu as de do de
le revoir regardez bien parce qu'on s'y
attend pas du four très for regardez bah
il a dit que c'était pas de sa faute les
2h30 de retard que c'était de la faute
des tournesols de la météo il a été de
mauvaise fois il a pas dit excuse-moi il
y a rien de précis qui se passe mais
disons que Maria c'était une femme
amoureuse de moi faut savoir ce qu'on
veut on est ensemble on plus je suis
désolé il a parlé de changer d'avis je
n'ai jamais changé d'avis attention faut
pas faut pas dire des choses que j'ai
pas dit ne sois pas de mauvaise fois moi
je te parle que de mauvaise fois é es-tu
tu veux arriver 2h30 en retard hier la
vie c'est toute une organisation mais
non
mais c'est énorme c'est la PR d'histoire
Joo j'adore alors il y a Justine aussi
qui est arrivée chez Patrice hier
c'était l'épisode que tout le monde
attendu l'eménagement de Justine chez
Patrice le seul problème euh c'est
qu'elle a confondu l'amour est dans le
prê avec recherche
appartement en fait c'est ça elle a tout
ramené he carton animaux de compagnie et
mauvaise humeur on l'embrasse quand
même quelqu'un à te présenter
P nul doute que panan va vite trouver
ses marques on va changer de chemise mon
cœur je suis désolé il t'a tout sal pan
m'a baptisé désolé c'est pas grave
combien il a le carton dans dans ta
camionnette je dirais minimum une bonne
trentaine och avec to
oui mais doucement mon cœur tu me mets
pas la pression s'il te plaît il faut
pas c'est incroyable alors généralement
je sais pas si vous êtes comme moi mais
quand des gens viennent vous aider pour
un déménagement généralement vous êtes
plutôt contents c'est sympa les potes
sont nus et cetera bah Justine une autre
technique en fait elle est un petit peu
chef de chantier elle donne des ordres
c'est presque à bout de la remercier
regardez on travaille à la chaîne donc
vous allez vous répartir comme vous
voulez sur le chemin et moi je vais être
ici pour faire le dispatch la chambre de
gauche et c'est lourd ça hein oui oui
c'est pour ça que j'ai marqué très lourd
et ça ça monte tout en haut deième étage
les colis lourds ils vont en haut pu les
colis légers ils vont si si c'est moi
qui commande maintenant la maîtresse de
maison c'est plus marieon c'est moi ici
ah oui Jean-Michel on ralenti ça va trop
vite là c'est pas un rally hein parce
que vous êtes en train de m'épuiser là
faut qu'il s'arrête en train de nous
tuer là tu vois bien ou pas merci à tous
d'être venu et puis rentrez bien merci
merci au revir au revoir bonne
soirée par contre
ça comment a dit Ron les déménageurs
fallait pas qu'il a un
piano si ça les déménageurs je les adore
je les adore mais les pauvres c'est vrai
que là il y a un piano est on est
mort on est marron ça fait quelques
heures que Justine est installée dans la
la maison et Justine elle prend très
très vite ses marques euu voilà ça
déplaît pas du tout à Patrice mais moi
ce que je les kiffe franchement je les
kiffe je les kiffe un peu ils ils sont
touchants quand même les parce que che
Justine elle a des problèmes elle a des
problèmes sur les réseaux vu dès que je
parle de problèmes je me tourne verg
bien sûr non
mais sur les réseaux c'est vrai qu'il y
a de la grossophobie elle est moquée
humiliée donc elle a beaucoup de de
mérite et c'est vrai que c'est une une
maîtresse femme mais voilà elle
s'installe et elle prend ses a il faut
condamner ce la production a suivait
énormément Justine ce qui se passait
autour d'elle parce qu'effectivement
elle était très affaiblie par tout ce
qui dis alors moi je les kiffe je rêve
de les avoir sur le
plateau qu'est que tu nous ramené de
beau i
abricot comm bien c'est pas
gentil tu vas au coin voilà je devrais
carrément te faire un petit fout de ma
gueule en ou
pour que leur avenir fleur bon l'amour
quoi de mieux que de planter un rosier
ensemble un peu plus sur ta gauche mon
cœur non la gauche la droite oui vers
moi légèrement et un peu plus
vers attends vers ma gauche vers ta
gauche I stop tu peux mettre un tout
petit peu vers ta droite voilà c'est
parfait
ici je tout
ému mon cœur
quand ta meuf elle met son nom sur la
boîteêtre c'est cuit ah ben je te le dis
là tu es mort tu es sûr et
certain cuitit les bananas c'est 20 en
ferme ta meuf quand elle fait ça là tu
es mort il y a deux trucs ça et le
paillasson si elle achète ellemême le
paillasson ah ou c'est oui qu'est-ce on
vous sent emboissé je j'ai vu beaucoup
de commentaires qui disaient qu'elle
avait de l'emprise sur lui qu'elle était
directrice et cetera et moi je trouve
qu'on contraire on voit beaucoup d'amour
et elle l'aime plus que tout et moi je
trouve ça génial je vois pas du tout à
quel moment elle de elle est dur avec
lui ou quoi que ce soit au contraire
elle lui rend bien bonsoir vous étiez
sur le banc de
r juste trîner non mais sans déconn
coach ouoi oui oui
guouou guou alors oui non mais je sens
qu'il va se Reber il y a eu deux trois
fois où il va pas se laisser faire donc
moi j'ai voilà j'ai confiance et j'ai
confiance se couple elle a pas l'air
dans la rébellion beaucoup là ils ont
encore ils ont encore jamais mis la
langue he pour l'instant ils
s'embrassent énormément mais ils ont
encore jamais mis la langue vous nous
préviendrez dès qu'il mett la langue
m'appelez vous avez un numéro je réponds
tout le temps d'cordcord allez on va
parler d'un autre agriculteur qui a fait
beaucoup réagir hier c'est Julien donc
c'est l'éleveur de de vach latiè et ces
deux prétendants Bastien et Tib qui
peuvent plus sentir entre les deux
heureusement c'est l'heure du choix
Julien annonce à Bastien qu' n' pas é
sélectionné et il est presque content ah
il est un peu libéré d'une certaine
tension mais ça se passe quand même pas
très bien ouais ça va vous êtes
passionn pour moi tu es une personne
formidable et tu vois j'ai eu le coup de
cœur lettre pour toi ouais et en fait
dans la réalité c'est pas une chose que
je ressens tu comprends ouais je te
donne mon point de vue sur la chose je
vais bienentendre je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec toi moi c'est pareil ça
n'a pas été
transformé
mais attends le gars il me dit qu'il a
pas ressenti le feeling alors que le
jour d'avant c'est oh ben on reviendra à
la grotte ensemble ah benah si tu veux
je peux te réchauffer non mais c'est pas
c'est pas possible quoi alors je vais
dire la vérité je dis àh52 je dis au
téléspectateurs Julien je suis d'accord
avec lui à fond c'est comme quand il y a
toujours un gars je va vous dire moi ça
m déà arrivé plein de fois des
gars es au club tu es en vacances et
cetera tu dis il y a une meuf tu dis
elle est super elle est fraîche tout ça
sauf que le gars qui n'a pas la toco
très vite oh finalement il est pas si
ouf que ça bah lui c'est exactement
pareil il a vu qu' passé au [__] et m'a
terminéavo la
fé alors je te dire la phrase
franchement en lettre je te kiffais par
contre en vrai je peux pas te délérer ça
franchement c'est extraordinaire alors
Julien a choisi donc Thib
mais Bastien insiste il voulait pas
rester vous voulez pas rester ça Julien
l'agriculteur il a vraiment du mal à le
digérer c'est le seul mec que ça vexe de
larguer quelqu'un regardez c'est vrai
que voilà au final je dire là dans cette
séquence vous allez voir des gens
excédés tu lui as dit ce que je t'ai dit
ou non vous en avz pas parlé ensemble
non ça vous regarde il y a pas de non
mais après je parlag le feeling passait
pas non plus pour moi envers Julien donc
voilà mais ça c'est quand même des
choses que je voudrais creuser tu me dis
clairement ah ben oui il y a pas eu de
feeling ça c'est complètement incohérent
pour moi ça ça m'énerve en fait parce
qu'en fait j'arrive pas à piger hier on
est à la grotte tu dis oh B oui pour
plus tard on reviendra machin tout ça et
là tu me sors ah ben oui le feeling en
fait il passait pas je dis honnêtement
ça me casse les couilles et je suis
content que tu t'en
ailles la est dans le Pr qu' cartonné
hier on va passer euh